if Amelia did survive on this island
there would be no avoiding this
formidable creature up to three feet
across and weighing in at over nine
pounds coconut crabs are the largest on
earth and many thousands of them team
over tiny nickim Ororo they're just
amazing their pincers are so strong that
they can climb trees and grab a bird and
you know kill it
they're also voracious scavengers as
demonstrated by tiger in 2007 with half
a pig carcass this creature was laid out
and they set up time-lapse cameras in
the trees and the results are about the
most disgusting thing you've ever seen
it
but it is very enlightening with help
from their smaller strawberry hermit
crab cousins they devour the carcass
within a week carrying the bones every
which way into their lairs the
scientists are now thinking something
similar would have happened to whoever
died at the wren so right now the
biggest hypothesis is to see if we can
find a crab burrow with the remains of
some humans right at the site that would
be like unbelievable
as they unleash the dogs to sniff out
remains they've already found some
tantalizing clues here over the decades
suggesting that person was Amelia
[Music]